foreign
[Music]
cruelty
you've been fighting the Harkins for
decades
my family's been fighting them for
centuries
they were massacred
alongside my father
your father didn't believe in Revenge
[Music]
let me fight beside you
reload
[Music]
he said that I got that
thanks
I won't be fighting for him
I'm fighting for my people
[Music]
you young pop
do you believe in Paul
there are signs
the prophet why is that a bad thing use
it because of all my Visions lead to
horror
because you lose control because I gain
it
Johnny do you believe in me
Paul the trades are still alive
deal with this prophet
[Music]
show me who you are
your father
was a weak man
look who's back from the dead
no do what must be done
we gave them something to hope for
I will love you as long as I breathe
this prophecy is how they
help me
it's not a prophecy it's a story I don't
care what you believe I believe
I'm miraculous
[Music]
who can destroy a thing has the real
control of it
[Music]
it's a peaceful place in the sky
are you going to heaven
no
why not
I gotta be a good person to go to heaven
10 years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
as long as AI is a threat
we will never stop hunting mountains
this is a fight for our very existence
whatever's in there they're sure worried
about someone getting in
yeah we're getting out
[Music]
we're just saying we can't go to heaven
because you're not good
[Music]
and I'm not a person
did you locate the weapon yeah it's a
key
belt
[Music]
we are this close to winning the war
execute her or we go extinct
they're coming to get me
thank you
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
[Music]
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
what does my mentor do besides bring me
roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in
that Arena
you start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games
[Music]
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
[Music]
there's a natural goodness built into us
all
across that line into evil
or not
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
[Music]
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance
the everything is about winning
the monsters
it's the things we love most and let's
try us
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's an ancient ecosystem Untouched by
man whatever is down there is trying to
make its way to the surface
this is a bad idea just a little bit
[Music]
Jonas
we've got company
it's the biggest night I've ever seen
biggest bag anyone's ever seen
that's the apex predator
everybody might get to the station
exit who knows what else have escaped
the breach
I just hope it goes better than last
time
what happened last time
you don't want to know
[Applause]
we've never seen this before they hunted
it back
oh
we can relax this place is Meg proof
when Jonas was always afraid of this but
I was also thinking let's go
[Music]
oh barracuda
did you hear me
foreign
[Music]
YouTube YouTube
[Applause]
my son never show Mercy
we
are predators
boys your mother is dead
she died because she sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind you know my
business yes
power is about strength if you show
weakness you will give our enemies an
opening
shot
this week like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off the six of us
and only one of you there's six of you
now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
I think you're some kind of Honor you
are exactly like our father just another
man hunting for a trophy
the murderers
isn't that what he taught us
we don't get to do that to me anymore
all right
Mr tagline
Mr tackling
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
you're goddamn lunatic oh you just
figured that out now
there is an animal I need to run up fast
don't you want to know why they call me
the rhino
thank you
foreign
we're just running errands that's it
sorry Splinter some of the guys wanted
to get pizza and I tried to talk him out
of it you ratted us out hey don't use
that word that way I mean
monsters that were shunned by society
and we could do what we wanted
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
yeah
it's insane Squirtle mutant karate team
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rap
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we take out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
huh I can't believe there are other
mutants you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we're gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
peoples they got to go okay um sort of a
twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dunk
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdom Raphael you
have bravery and Leonardo honor
talk I dream about fighting every night
you've got a rage problem right it's not
a problem
this is Bella
Bella this is Mr McCandless hello fella
[Music]
no
she's an experiment good evening her
brain and her body are not quite
synchronized
but she's progressing at an accelerated
pace
[Music]
tell me where did she come from
I shall
or it is a happy tail
[Music]
I am Bella Baxter and there is a world
to enjoy so I can navigate it is the
goal of all to progress grow a woman
plotting her cause of freedom and do not
fall
[Music]
good
job
[Music]
oh
we're in the middle of an ongoing War
we love that the big guys join the fight
[Music]
roll out
wow that was corny when I said it out
loud
[Music]
everybody out here
if you keep your eyes open class will
show you everything you need to know now
let's talk to your manifestation
[Music]
together
Transformers rise of the Beast yeah turn
it up I'm never leaving Brooklyn again
oh my soul
you know you really captured his Essence
maybe his face could use a lot more
detail though
it's like a photograph I'm Adam Chloe
[Music]
so you're not gonna make fun of me
all right
oh my God
this might be the nicest thing anyone's
ever done for me
[Music]
you have 62 viewers and 300 total
they don't have love in their culture
they find romantic stuff super exotic
and interesting
they watch you'll go on dates
one of our most cherished human rituals
[Music]
in broadcast
hey would you keep that out of my
line of sight why don't you keep your
out of our line of sight you didn't
invent courtship broadcast
please
[Music]
it has recently become obvious you are
deceiving your viewers what deceiving
the title titled your broadcast is Adam
and Chloe in love
and in love
I want you to repay all funds you have
received wait we've already spent
everything we made just to live
then I will
and your families will be in debt for
approximately six Generations
want me to cut that for you
where is the nearest restaurant
no part of my body can make that noise
well it certainly won't if you don't try
[Music]
to get that love back
romantic love is the most poetic of all
human love gods it should never be faked
I'm just like any other person I want to
grow up and fall in love and be swept
off my feet
we've lost a lot since you guys came
here
thank you
but we've overcome a lot too
foreign
[Music]
I'm Spider-Man
he's going to be here any minute heard
me your money so are you like a cow or a
Dalmatian ah Spiderman
there's bubbles now hold on
I don't think I want this costume
anymore how's this going miles's grades
are pretty good A and AP Physics that's
my little man and a B in Spanish
miles wanna get out of here no come true
spider Society I'm Spiderman oh no way
all of us are
Miguel O'Hara there's moments in our
stories that are the same for all of us
some good did you bring our baby to
another fight you asked me not to so I
didn't in bed you have a choice between
saving one person and saving every world
I can do both all stations stop
Spiderman you know
[Music]
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah I'm gonna do my
own thing
because they get any weirder
I guess it can
there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run two seconds this film does not get
rated
what the hell are you doing
entering the jump Point perimeter
gonna get you some readings Fury
hello hello
[Music]
where's Captain Rambo
what the hell yeah
hi we're looking for Kamala Khan
okay so our powers are entangled I can
manipulate light energy and you I could
totally show you
one again
hi where's our daughter wherever you
were
[Applause]
[Music]
a team oh no no no we're not we're not a
team
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thing I know we are the greatest heroes
in the universe we're not Heroes we're
the Guardians of the Galaxy
yeah that looked cool
he's Guardians are more powerful than
you think
[Applause]
I will destroy them
oh hell
[Applause]
[Music]
are you ready
One Last Ride hello we come in peace
[Music]
come on tracks seriously dude
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I love you thank you passing you into
Mr Wayne no please don't stop I need you
here now Barry
so you're saying you could travel back
in time
but Bruce I can fix things I can save
people I can save my mom I could save
your parents
you can also destroy everything
I love you too so how was it this week
how's school Google was good
this is mad trippy dude this is
catastrophic
foreign
let's get nuts
we're in Uncharted Territory
we try not to die
are you ready ready let's go
[Music]
we have fancy friends
yo who's an Uber
exec
I had a vision
people burning
everything destroyed it was Athena she
was doing it
I was doing it why won't let that happen
I saw what you did in the ring
I knew it had to be you say it
what if I told you Sienna here is The
Reincarnation of the goddess Athena
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
feel to be a goddess sometimes I feel
like I'm a guest in my own body
to start your training the Pegasus night
is Brave
humble and committed to protecting
Athena with his life
how would you do that
a word that Oasis is unlike any other
before
[Music]
I think I wanted any of this
his powers of liability once he learns
to control it no living man will be able
to stop
you might want to buckle up
though you were the only night in town
most people with abilities I detect
Young
at five or six
maybe we can start with a name
Aurora
[Applause]
[Music]
unlike normal people bro
these abilities only work a few are in
control
[Music]
so what's his name
whose name we're not playing that game
you want to keep secrets and shield them
better in your mind how about you stand
on my head and give me some privacy
ask you about your abilities I like to
do projections you say you hate what
we're reading yeah you love that garbage
that's good can you move objects I'm not
good at it
you need a teacher Rob these abilities
they're complicated they're
transformative
and they can be dangerous underneath
let's go come on I'm not going with you
[Music]
mom I need you to start telling me the
truth no more lies just trying to give
you the tools to protect yourself who
yes
she's freaking out
please please leave me alone
[Music]
something isn't right
I don't know what's going on
I need to find a way back yes
what can you tell us about this wizard I
could take you to his castle beyond that
you're the ones intent on dying
she's an angel come to save us
never seen anyone fight like that
you're a Wanderer
we have to kill them before they kill us
the only way to stop their Invasion cats
you said you wanted to prove yourself
this is the time
evil is as unstoppable
that's why we fight for those that can't
a good man knows that Darkness will
always be there and stands against it
anyway
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
Charter 373
this is Commander Mills my ship was hit
by an undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
on a long-range exploratory mission
[Music]
send help
the crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
I don't know where we are
I've located One Survivor
a giant
the atmosphere is breathable
there's something alien out there
foreign
you and I are gonna get home oh
finally ready
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]